des centaines de producteurs de sirop
d'érable mécontents ont manifesté à
québec aujourd'hui
ils protestent contre le rapport gagné
qui propose revoir la façon de
commercialiser le sirop d'érable pour
éviter que l'industrie me perdre encore
plus de parts de marché au niveau
mondial
pendant ce temps certains d'entre eux
ont peut-être trouvé une solution pour
se démarquer une solution écologique
bonsoir catherine masson céline vous
avez mis la main sur un rapport de
producteurs du bas saint laurent les uns
conclusions de ce rapport sont assez
étonnantes en fait et céline si je vous
demande comment fait on pour faire
bouillir l'eau d'érable pour obtenir
notre fameux sirop vous allez
probablement me répondent en faisant
brûler du bois
c'est l'image bucolique on a de la
cabane à sucre d'antan est en fait plus
de la moitié de notre or blonde 53% de
sirop d'érable québécois est obtenue en
faisant brûler de l'or noir du mazout
pour un litre de sirop il faut brûler en
moyenne 0,6 litre de mazout se sont donc
près de 12 millions de litres de ce
combustible fossile qui servent à
produire notre sirop à l'échelle du
québec
c'est ce qui ressort d'un rapport d'un
club da serriculteurs du bas saint
laurent
c'est la deuxième région en importance
pour la production acéricole aux
producteurs oui tout à fait derrière
l'argentin
quelle solution est ce qu'il propose ils
disent il faut rapidement faire une
transition énergétique et il propose
deux solutions d'électricité ou les
granules de bois l'électricité on sait
qu'on en a des surplus c'est une énergie
propre produite localement les granules
de bois la biomasse
si la valorisation des sous produits de
la forêt davis la sciure de bois etc
ça crée des emplois en région et s'est
aussi produit localement évidemment et
ces granules de bois elles sont
carboneutre oui parce qu'on considère
que lorsqu on les brûle ça émet la même
quantité de co2 que si elles se
décomposent est dans la nature et donc
ce qui ressort du rapport ses comptes au
talent leur retirer le mazout de la
production de sirop d'érable permettrait
une réduction de 32 mille tonnes de gaz
à effet de serre ça ça équivaut au
retrait de 12 mille voitures de la
circulation environ oui c'est pas énorme
et on sait que le québec s'est doté de
cibles ambitieuses près de 40% de
réduction de ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2030 donc il faudra
aller chercher toutes ces solutions là
mais cette transition évidemment elle va
avoir un coût
oui au final on dit la facture d'énergie
sera moins élevé mais acheter les
nouveaux équipements évidemment ça coûte
des sous les auteurs du rapport estiment
qu'avec 50 millions de dollars
le milieu acéricole arriverait à se
défaire de sa dépendance au mazout qui
soit dit en passant provient presque
exclusivement d'étrangers donc se
tourner vers l'électricité ou les
granules de bois c'est bon pour
l'environnement mais c'est bon aussi
pour l'économie locale
donc les fonds pourraient provenir entre
autres de l'aide accordée par le bureau
de l'efficacité de l'innovation
énergétique à différents programmes de
subventions mais les producteurs disent
on a besoin d'engagement à long terme
parce que parfois ces subventions là
elles vont ils viennent et là les
investissements sont importants ils ne
peuvent pas être amorti là sur deux ou
trois ans donc c'est parfait mais quand
même un dossier à suivre intéressant
merci de concret